this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today as precisely one person
mentioned it in the comments
and we thought you know what it's not a
bad idea actually we're going to be
taking a look at the third person
shooter classic
splatoon 2. it makes spongebob
squarepants look like shakespeare
if you want to see more of jonathan
reacting to video game firearms make
sure to hit that subscribe button and if
there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you want to see jonathan
break down let us know in the comments
section below
if you'd like to help out the royal
armies museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description
of this video right over to jonathan
well this is quite a specific type of
weapon serving
dual functions so it's capable of
engaging
personnel uh it's also uh capable of
effectively taking ground on its own
by essentially splattering the ground
with your side's colour not something
that we're used to seeing on the on the
historical firearm side of things but as
it happens we do have
a close parallel perhaps this is what
the game is basing this weapon on
um which is this the relatively modern
weapon dates to the early 1990s in its
original form
it's not quite it's not a perfect match
for for what we see as i say this is
obviously a game and this is
this is a real a real thing so this is
the xp 100
something of a classic in this field um
probably the main
point of departure here is that this has
the
slightly more old-fashioned pump system
which
charges the bottle at the rear here
with atmospheric gases to
help with the delivery of the payload
which of course in this case is not
colored
slime it's a very prolific chemical
known as dihydrogen monoxide
which can be fatal in sufficient
quantities
and this this is more than capable of
delivering those quantities once you
once you've
pumped it up enough the reloading on
this is i mean it's it's obviously uh
highly stylized in the game but uh the
real real thing you rotate the locking
collar
uh remove the the bottle the charge
bottle uh not really a magazine wouldn't
it wouldn't be correct to call it that
but in theory uh drop on another one or
fill it up from a convenient
backpack or similar rotate the locking
collar and um
ready to pump it up to continue uh the
fight so
of course camouflage for for this sort
of application it's really the opposite
of that it's um eye-catching quite
similar to
the way that the version in the game is
depicted but um
regarded as a classic by many and um
we'll be uh adding this to as you can
see adding this to the
royal armouries collection forthwith
we make spongebob squarepants look like
shakespeare
uh something that we can't hope to
replicate from our collection is
of course the giant uh for one of for
better phrase paint roller now i've not
used a
weapon of that nature myself but i have
painted my house
on occasion and i'm not sure of the
realism in terms of the
the fluid dynamics of what we're seeing
here with one color
overlaying another without any mixing
but clearly the
um the gameplay dictates that one color
is competing with another so i think we
can allow that one
right that's quite enough of that now
this is interesting
because we've got a weapon for
delivering the
colored substance that's that's critical
to the to the gameplay
and of course to certain battlefields in
in the real world um
but the the for want of a better term
paint gun is
in this case closely based on the fn p90
submachine gun and has a similar sort of
rate of fire so i think
in this case they've taken a departure
from the very serious issue of uh
combat with coloured liquids to bring in
a bit of
the more mundane military world with a
sort of
goo version of a p90 which is which is
fun and then we see
a an interesting man portable
multiple launch rocket system which
which has quite a dramatic effect
upon the enemy as we can see
[Music]
thanks for watching everyone i hope
you've enjoyed this take on
the weapons of splatoon 2. if you'd like
to support our work here at the royal
armouries we have links in the
description as to
how you can do that but and i hope we'll
see you again
next time and um april fool's needless
to say
[Music]
[Music]
you